so last week a Canadian youtuber with a
controversial reputation uploaded a
video claiming that his girlfriend had
died in a car accident
except that she didn't and he admitted
that he lied about the entire thing and
now he says that there was a warrant out
for his arrest
okay so this is Jason EDA or J station
another banger video we just received
another crazy email from a girl claiming
to hear baby noises coming from inside
of her wall he's a youtuber known for
having this kind of anything for the
views approach to his content from
24-hour challenges to elaborate pranks
to talking with Jesus at 3 a.m. on this
stupid phone app his entire stick is
built around making clickbait videos
that become insanely popular like you
know when you're watching something and
it feels wrong like you're just stuffing
your eyeballs with crunchy Cheetos
yeah that [ __ ] is his bread and butter
well all seven there's no way Jesus and
now he's back in the news because he
made a bunch of videos faking his
girlfriend's death before admitting that
he lied about the entire thing in an
effort to grow his YouTube channel but
before I break down how insane this
story actually is let's just run through
how he got here in the first place J
station has been uploading content since
2016 and his reputation within the
YouTube community well it's never been
great in a recent video from June 2019
he claims that he was the victim of a
home invasion except a bunch of people
called him out and saying that it was
fake and to my knowledge he's never
publicly addressed these allegations
that same month on June 26th the same
day that popular youtuber Etica died J
station uploaded at 3 a.m. Ouija board
challenge where he claims he spoke to
Etica from the afterlife
now this video is obviously in poor
taste and people were pissed calling the
video manipulative and insensitive and a
petition was even started to get J
station banned from YouTube while J
stations content is at the very least
insensitive he does represent this kind
of darker microcosm of content on
YouTube because while people like Jake
Paul ksi and rice gum have built massive
followings off of clickbait videos that
over-exaggerated the truth
J station is different this dude just
straight-up lies in the majority of his
content and
how he still has 5 million subs now J
station has a second channel called
Dream Team where he would upload content
with his girlfriend Alexia Morano the
person he claims died in the car crash
the content here is pretty similar lots
of challenges pranks and holy [ __ ]
headlines designed to get you to tune in
and this brings us to last week where
things got very weird J station uploaded
a video to his primary channel called my
girlfriend Alexia has died rest in
Paradise and like I said this is where
he claims that Alexia had died in a car
accident after that there was a roadside
memorial video and yeah another 3 a.m.
Ouija board challenge trying to contact
her from the afterlife given this
history people were immediately
skeptical Twitter was going nuts over it
and one youtuber claim that the Ottawa
police said nobody matching Alexa's name
or description had been in a car
accident
we at chop the point news have a source
inside the Ottawa Police Department and
we were told absolutely nobody with that
name has been in a car accident or was
reported killed in a car accident now I
called both the Ottawa and Toronto
police departments and they confirmed to
me that nobody matching Alexia's name or
description had been in a car accident
in fact the Ottawa Police Department
told me that as of January 24th there
had only been two fatal collisions in
2020 now one was an 87 year old woman
and the other was a 38 year old woman
neither of which were Alexia so at this
point I was pretty skeptical about J
stations story and holy [ __ ] did it get
worse because Monday morning January
27th 2020 J station uploaded a video to
YouTube called Alexia Morano the truth
about her I expected all this to stay on
YouTube and it didn't
and basically guys what I need to tell
you is that Alexia is gone Alexia was
never dead yeah he lied about the entire
thing
Alexia wasn't in a car accident and she
didn't die and his explanation for why
he made the videos in the first place
well it's [ __ ] wild so we thought of
the idea actually I thought it though
about the idea what if we faked your
death do a skit on YouTube pranking
everybody just to gain traction on the
dream team Channel okay so now we have a
youtuber known for making clickbait
videos now making content about his dead
girlfriend who wasn't actually dead all
for the views he goes on to say that at
first Alexia was cool with making these
fake death videos until and I quote she
started getting phone calls from her
parents and they didn't like it yeah no
[ __ ] they didn't like it and he's like
sitting in this closet talking about the
fact that it's none of her parents
business what they do online and then he
says that Alexia just dipped grabbed all
her stuff and left but then he says that
Alexia went to the cops she's still not
talking to me then she go into the
police and tell her I assaulted her with
a weapon and not have warrants on my
arrest and at this point I'm like what
in the actual [ __ ] is going on because
now we're talking about assault charges
and if this is true this story has gone
from a scuzzy youtuber making clickbait
videos to something much much more
serious so again I called the Ottawa and
Toronto Police Department's and as of
January 27th there is no arrest warrants
out for somebody under the name of Jason
at Ta in the video there are brief
glimpses of cops at his door but you
never really hear what they're saying so
we don't know what they were talking
about and yeah according to the Ottawa
Police Department
those weren't real cops that showed up
to Jay station's door so we have a
youtuber going from making [ __ ]
clickbait videos to faking an alleged
home invasion to now making fake content
about his girl
death who isn't dead and the fact that
the police are looking for it one of the
more strange parts about all of this is
the fact that we haven't heard from
Alexia like at all everything I just
told you from her being okay with the
fake death videos to the breakup to the
alleged assault charges it's all coming
from Jay Station I have a feeling that
we're not quite done with this story yet
which is brutal because no matter what
he says it's hard to tell what is
actually true or false and I guess if
like an alleged bus drives through his
alleged house maybe I'll be talking
about him again well we do and we make
like I say that like you can you do you
wait you want you you could do so well I
wasn't trying to scream I was just I had
a couple funny ideas I'm naturally loud
[ __ ] dinosaurs existed the earth is
round
get over yourself boy that escalated
quickly I mean that really got out of
hand fast